[Music]
they had wanted to move
out of the caves into more permanent
english-built structures
the caves were only a temporary place
where the first settlers arrived in
it's the year 1681
followers of william penn have arrived
in the new world from england looking
for religious freedom
once here on the banks of the delaware
river they create homes out of the earth
itself
in caves
the
settlers their inclination was to build
on the waterfront and that's what they
did
historian harry karakotis describes
those early days the future americans
settled in these holes which had been
already there by the river
for the
possible catching of muskrats
by the indians
this small community started in those
caves will very shortly become the city
of philadelphia the first capital of the
united states the quakers eventually
moved out but the caves continued to be
used for many decades as the city grew
they became bars and brothels
while others became part of the
basements
of houses along front street
and
those houses or those businesses still
exist along one certain era of front
street that's part of old city
philadelphia
and the caves are still there deep under
the homes of the busiest parts of
philadelphia very close to where highway
95 intersects with the benjamin franklin
bridge kirakotis has been in one
it looks like a basement but you know
from descending into it that you're
going deeper into earth than the outside
area that you came from
going deeper into the earth that
instinct has played a part in human
history in ways that we can't always see
but it is part of our collective history
our present and perhaps our future
where you may be standing at any given
time is only part of the story there is
much much more down below
i'm davar ardalan and this is overheard
at national geographic a show where we
eavesdrop on the wild conversations we
have here at natrio and follow them to
the edges of our big weird beautiful
world
[Music]
and today we're going underground we'll
get to know the modern day versions of
underland dwellers in hatch rock utah
cooper pd australia and sacramento spain
communities who choose to live in caves
away from daylight in the depths of the
earth more after the break
[Music]
i think of the underground it's like a
lost continent there's so much down
there that we do not
understand that we
cannot see that it's just like this
weird frontier for exploration
weird in that it's
really close to where we're
sitting right now
and yet it's completely alien william
hunt has been exploring the lost
continent of the underground since he
was a teenager he's a cave expert and
author who thinks about what is below
our feet constantly as far as what is
directly beneath us right now
anywhere you go in the world
there are
these
nests of infrastructure that we never
think about there are
ancient
buried cities archaeological sites there
are
caves that may be totally unexplored
there are
beneath that
giant tectonic plates that are grinding
up against each other and then way down
beneath that is the core of the earth
which is
basically like a black box as far as
we're concerned at this point
we've barely made a dent in our
understanding of the caves and tunnels
that make up our earth's underground
hunt says by some estimates half of the
world's caves are unexplored and yet our
fascination runs deep
caves are sort of like the hidden aspect
of existence
it's the hidden aspect of existence that
chilean photographer and national
geographic explorer tamara moreno set
out to find underground
the images she brought to the surface
show us how whole communities live their
lives in a seemingly unconventional
fashion
they venture into the darkness every day
for very different reasons
reasons which nonetheless connect them
to our prehistoric and even pre-human
relationship with caves the first time i
went to the dark room and i saw how my
images start appearing you know these
these grain grains and start like
appearing this photograph i thought this
was a magical moment and i wanted to do
this for the rest of my life
tamara marino uses photography to share
hidden stories including her powerful
images of life underground her work has
taken her to the utah desert the
australian outback and andalusia spain
all in the name of helping us imagine
what we cannot see
in paris in the 1860s it was a
photographer who captured the city's
imagination of the now infamous
subterranean parisian world so felix
nadar who just went by nadar was a
sort of fixture in
the sort of bohemian
art world of paris in the 19th century
he
was extremely
flamboyant and in 1861 he
invented
a battery operated light which is the
first of its kind in photography it
allowed a photographer to take pictures
without natural light and to show off
his magic lantern as he called it he
took it into the darkest
place he could find which is the
catacombs and sewers of paris
and spent several months taking
photographs of the hidden underside of
the city
nadar and his crew lugged heavy
equipment down below each exposure took
18 minutes
when
the
photographs were published they had this
really
profound impact on the imagination of
parisians
people who knew that their city had
these underground systems beneath it
they knew about the catacombs they knew
that the sewers were down there they
were mostly kind of
dark
threatening unknown spaces nadar's
photographs illuminated a part of the
city that parisians couldn't see they
saw these images and they became
fascinated and they wanted to go visit
these places people would you know dress
up in their sunday's finest and go
wandering through these
dark tunnels it became sort of a fad on
a weekend night to pop open a manhole
and climb down to the sewer system and
sort of walk in the footsteps of nadar
and he's
described as this sort of mythological
hero who has traveled to the land of the
dead and reemerged on the surface with a
new kind of power
that power of going down into a cave
into the belly of the earth and coming
back to tell the tale is the most
powerful story of the underground and it
goes all the way back to the beginning
of human history if you look at
the mythological systems of cultures all
over the world it's universal there's
always an underworld even with cultures
that don't have
physical
caves
around them
there is an underworld
[Music]
ancient cave dwellings can be found all
over the world in places like mathmata
tunisia kandavan iran and inside the
high cliffs of mesa verde in what is now
the southwestern corner of colorado
and today some 30 million people
currently live in caves in china
burrowing inside the yellow porous soil
of the shanxi province
president xi jinping reportedly lived in
one of these caves for seven years as a
young man his parents were exiled there
during the cultural revolution
[Music]
a red dirt road is the only approach to
hatch rock
in tamra's aerial photo the road splits
into a v framing a huge red rock that
rises nearly 500 feet out of the
landscape
i arrived to this massive rock in the
middle of the desert
and this was like a it has
the crescent shape of the moon and it
was amazing
tucked into the base of hatch rock is
rockland ranch a community of modern
cave dwellers in eastern utah these
caves are built in the massive red
sandstone formation so the houses were
built by blasting dynamt into the
sandstone cliff and then covering the
cave walls to create modern homes with
running water electricity internet
access
the community who has lived here since
the 1970s are fundamentalist mormons
they refer to this place simply as the
rock
enoch foster is the son of the rock's
original founder self-sufficiency is a
basic tenet of this polygamous community
and so over the last 15 17 years we've
built
15 homes and cabins and solar systems
and putting wells and putting water
systems and water lines and garden lines
and
they live off the grid with their own
water well and are powered by solar
energy this helps them stay under the
radar in a state that outlaws bigamy and
to avoid the mormon mainstream who shuns
it basically we want to live as
naturally as we can
and living in the rock helps us build to
do that reduces our
pollution reduces
what we need is to sustain life
the images that tamara captured at the
rock reflect the driving reason people
have sought shelter in caves for
centuries to escape the apocalypse
enoch foster is carrying out his
father's vision which was to prepare for
and survive what they believe will be
the end of days
he
believed in
a time when the earth was going to
change to
to
to
a different way of being
and he always believed that there would
be
you know wars and troubles come before
that
so to come and begin building
a community that he hoped would last
into the far future
there is a biblical passage that states
and they shall go into the holes of the
rocks and into the caves of the earth
the rock is a very literal
interpretation of that mandate
when tamara arrived one family was in
the midst of carrying it out so that
first day i helped them build the cave
they were building
and it was really fascinating to see
them
how they were turning this cave into a
home it was amazing and there were still
no light bulbs on the roof so the
lighting was coming from the flashlights
from their hands or from their heads
and
it was really like watching all these
people working collectively felt like
being inside an anthill
this act of creating space underground
has compelled whole cultures to seek
shelter in this fashion
i think that as
dark and threatening as a cave can be or
as a subterranean borough can be
as afraid as we are of being buried
alive there's something like deeper than
that and some
glimmer of
deep psyche that you're back in your
mother's womb
more after the break
across the globe in the southern
australian outback modern cave dwellers
have been burrowing underground for an
entirely different reason mining
tamara found herself there in 2015
seemingly in the middle of nowhere with
a flat tire
i started looking at the landscape and i
was really
enchanted because it has like a
mysterious lunar landscape
the sand is really red and it's a deep
orange it's beautiful
for about a century this extremely
remote town has been known as the opel
capital of the world but tamara says you
wouldn't know it from the surface
everything from dive bars to restaurants
to churches is built below the surface
and for good reason
so this was in november so it was almost
summer it was really really hot
it was almost 120 degrees outside
the extreme heat has driven the
population to live alongside their
precious opal down below but don't call
them caves locals refer to their homes
as dugouts
tamara got her flat tire fixed but she
decided to stay and get to know some of
the residents including opel miner
martin fagador he invited tamara to see
the dugout that he calls home see here
was something he did as well
when he opened the door he gave me a
head torch to walk through the tunnels
of his underground house and that was an
amazing moment you know i remember
thinking
if i need a head torch to walk around
his town i mean i'm gonna be walking in
dark tunnels you know
the dugouts in cooper pd hold steady at
around 75 degrees fahrenheit tamara
captured the sense of coolness inside
gabrielle gulen's home in a photograph
of her kitchen a room with raw cave
walls a piece of muslin is seen covering
a hole in the ceiling
tamra stayed here with gabby for a few
nights every morning when i woke up my
blanket was covered with dust and small
pieces of soil that had fallen from the
ceiling during the night
and i remember feeling that the earth
was alive you know it was constantly
changing tamara got to see just how much
that underground was changing when she
was invited to visit one of the opel
mines
hey we went down 15 meters sitting on an
electric winch
and it was a hole about one meter wide
and
for a moment this 45 seconds journey
down seems like an eternity this was the
first time i was going down so deep in
the earth
and when i was going down little stones
fell off while i was going down the
shaft
down in the mine was completely dark
and
when we were down
they have just some spotlights on the
entrance and walking around with a torch
on your hand is like
going in a labyrinth that doesn't lead
you anywhere you know
the farther down she went the more
deeply she felt connected with one of
the most ancient human relationships to
the earth
one of the oldest ways we've interacted
with the underground is to go into the
earth to extract valuable minerals from
beneath the surface it has always been a
spiritual act more specifically a
spiritually anxious act
across the world and throughout history
you find stories of traditional cultures
going underground to mine minerals
and
having to appease a sort of
a mine spirit like an earth spirit that
protects the mind
the opal mines in cooper pd still embody
some of that ancient anxiety
opal is there somewhere they just have
to find it this stone is going to change
their lives they stay and live in the
mind because they are afraid of somebody
else coming and stealing their opal the
opal fever as they call it overrides the
dangers of mining when there is always
the risk of collapse or underground
flooding and the chances of discovering
opal of value are unpredictable at best
if you can find it
this needle in a haystack stuff but
we came across
the most beautiful opal i went with the
light and around the corner and this
thing in the wall just
was like a third eye
right it was orange
and
it was beautiful and it was just
glittering with sugared opal bright
orange
nature creates anything you can imagine
tamara says for martin fagger the value
of living underground goes well beyond
the elusive opal it's a way of life
the tradition of underground living in
australia has been prized for millennia
by aboriginal cultures stretching back
as far as 46 000 years the yukon gorge
caves in the pilbara region
these rock shelters were decimated in
2020 by rio tinto a mining conglomerate
in search of iron ore they have been
ordered to restore the site
the scorching temperatures in utah and
australia are undeniably part of the
reason these underground dwellings are
so imminently practical so practical in
fact that william hunt believes a strong
case can be made for a future where
caves will provide a refuge from the
ever-increasing impact of climate change
i don't think it's a stretch to say that
you know we could be looking at a
version of the future of humanity as
things heat up and they get really hot
it would make sense for us to take
shelter in naturally cool subterranean
settings could this be the way of the
future
from her travels around the world tamara
marino thinks so living underground is
an eco-friendly and optimistic solution
for the environment and it is completely
self-sustaining as in the case of utah
and in kuberpedia australia and it
reduces the impact on the terrain
through a carbon footprint of
practically zero you know that leaves
the case with a constant temperature so
they don't need heating system or air
conditioning system
so all these communities i have
documented really show
us how we can go back to the basis
because i feel like today we are the
ones who have to inhabit the world in a
different ways and they are really being
an example for us
with so much of the planet at risk from
higher temperatures it would seem that
many might still need to be convinced of
the benefits of dark deep subterranean
living
while underground life may not be for
everyone it's already happening
it's becoming more and more common
to have
apartment buildings that go not only
above the surface but deep below the
surface they're already starting to
build down into the ground to create
large-scale housing for the population
in east asian mega cities
if this is the case then what does the
future look like how will our long
relationship with caves impact the way
we live our lives as the planet changes
i think of
future
archaeologists coming to look at our
society now and in the immediate future
i wouldn't be shocked if they see this
trend of retreating into naturally cool
cave spaces or subterranean spaces and
cities
if the caves in the andalusia region of
spain are any indication underground
living is in no way on the wane as one
of the oldest continuous cave dwelling
communities in europe it is thriving
according to tamara moreno it is also
enchanting
her photographs and videos of
underground flamenco dancers show how
much life is inside these caves there
were pants and pots hanging
all over the ceiling that ceiling was
dome shaped painted white
the light was deemed but not dark
completely
a few colored lights glowed on the walls
in reds greens and blues it's moody and
festive
then a dancer enters and she appears in
the middle of the darkness and begins to
dance and on her face i could really see
an expression of nostalgia like she was
suffering
but i could tell that it was pure
passion running through her veins
the room is captivated
but the crowd is small on either side of
the dancer just a single row of chairs
looks on
and she keeps on tapping and suddenly
she starts
rubbing her hands against her body until
she reaches the ceiling
and then she started to clap
really really hard
you could feel really the vibration of
the music
in your skin
you could feel how it moves you
moment i started crying
tears were falling down my face but
those were tears of joy of happiness
because i felt like i was transported
like 500 years back
to see the first dancing of flamenco
this cave near granada is part of
sacramente a mountain where caves have
existed for hundreds of years
the residents have lived on the margins
of the larger society since it was
founded
it's where some jewish and muslim
populations escaped to avoid being
forced to convert to christianity in
1492 and since that time it has been
home to thousands who are fleeing both
the constraints of conventional life as
well as political turmoil
this theme is strong in cave dwelling
communities as with the mormons of hatch
rock or the quakers on the banks of the
delaware
here in sacramento on the outskirts of
society the zambra flamenco specific to
this region was born hundreds of years
ago
similar to the caves it was an act of
resistance until these days these gypsy
families retain their traditional cave
lifestyle alive with more strength than
ever
today this mountain is porous with caves
that are inhabited by people from all
over the world including immigrants from
elsewhere in europe and africa they are
here in part for the freedom that comes
with living underground this is another
powerful piece of the story of our
relationship with caves so that is
something that i have seen
a lot
all over the world where you have
marginalized people
who don't have a place or don't feel
comfortable in
kind of normalized
surface
spaces in a given place and so they
retreat into cave spaces
tamara spent some time with a cave
dweller named tokuato lopez who was born
in sacramente
the photo she captured is of a
well-dressed gentleman sitting in a room
with a very low ceiling surrounded by
large colorful stuffed animals
his room is in the deepest part of the
cave and this room does not have windows
it doesn't have natural light and
toquato was sitting on the edge of the
bed with the photograph of his father
hanging next to him on the wall
and it was really a magical moment but a
little bit spooky i have to say because
not fresh air was coming in and the
darkness of the earth
it could be really felt
many of the residents of sacramento like
so many throughout human history have
deep spiritual connections to places
like this where the darkness acts not as
a threat but as a refuge
i remember toquato once told me i'm very
proud of being from the caves and i will
die inside a cave
national geographic explorer tamara
moreno she hopes to travel next to
tunisia mexico and china as she
continues to document the lives of
underlined dwellers digging even deeper
into our human relationship to the
underground
[Music]
if you like what you hear and want to
support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a national geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard go to not geo.com
explore to subscribe
the underland photos that explore tamara
marina captured can be seen online at
nationalgeographic.com
will hunt's book underground a human
history of the world beneath our feet
will take you much deeper into that
topic
links to these resources can be found in
the overheard show notes in your podcast
app
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by marcy thompson elana strauss
brian gutierrez and jacob pinter our
senior producer is carla wales our
senior editor is eli chen our fact
checkers are robin palmer and julie beer
our copy editor is amy kolczak
this episode was sound designed and
engineered by ted woods
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners the national
geographic society committed to
illuminating and protecting the wonder
of our worlds funds the work of national
geographic explorer tamara
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences susan
goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director and i'm your host and
executive producer of audio davar
ardalon thanks for listening
[Music]
you